I'm not Robin of Loxley anymore we're
doing an origin sort of story or an
origin tyke if you mark on it so olive
has very much freed himself from the
constraints of a realism or a
faithfulness to period this is an inside
job
who do you think the thief is clearly
he's well-trained adaptable under fire
get him eventually I just don't know
that anyone wants to see another
traditional Robin Hood movie so the
whole point is that we speak in a way
that feels contemporary and current and
relevant when I actually get to you know
steel
[Music]
well sugar it's been a long long haul
finally because everybody kind of goes
over period period pursue the same old
castles the same old Abbey's there's
nothing of that in this movie at all
it's got there's none of that
traditional period stuff at all
it's an extraordinary looking film I
cannot say enough about this young man
he put his name in the ledger of playing
Robin Hood silently when I first saw my
scene because the first the first scene
you got 90 days he has done a fantastic
job
he hasn't been privy to see some of the
footage that I've seen do you think the
thief is he's all of us he's not are you
sure
as a hell of a ride his journey is very
very traumatic
I needed an actor who had real death in
town is very very very talented actor
and can really do that heavyweight stuff
and we've got the Jamie Foxx he was a
mighty entity
I wanted to create this really really
fun sort of like ebuddy relationship
between Little John and Robin Hood they
start off as mortal enemies and they try
and kill each other in the first scenes
of the movie they become one sec because
Jamie's a singer Taran staying in a
movie we had to do something because it
was freezing out there man
it was cold warmer so on paper like
[Laughter]
[Music]